you here with L Russell you're tuned in
I'm on the bootleg care podcast you know
what's going on about to get into
another interview brought to you by my
bookie it's holiday season that means
bowl games NBA in season tournament NFL
all going down let's make this money
right now if you sign up at my bookie
and use my promo code bootleg claim your
deposit match that's right put a deposit
in up to $1,000 they're going to match
it
mybookie.ag promo code is bootleg let's
get to the interview
boot Lake head podcast special guest
here L Russell's in the building ah we
back he needs no introduction come on
the man who's changing the music game in
my opinion little by little it's working
I just saw dizzy W post something today
about how he just dropped his project
and like uh 200 fans supported it I
think on the same platform you're using
even even and uh the crazy thing is is
he showed the stream
equivalency and that to me I think is
like I think it was like in his first
day it was like the money he made was
like 1.4 million streams worth of money
right which is crazy because you know
these companies are [__] everybody
hey you
know it's a tough topic cuz they're not
[__]
everyone like streaming is an extra
Revenue but people are treating it like
it's the main one is that fair to say
exactly and that's the issue it's like
bro they really created something
revolutionary like I'm I'm grateful for
streaming I get paid monthly off some
[__] that I typically you feel me but
it's like I I get people's SCP but it's
like man they were trying to do
something and and they did do something
Innovative and game changing it's like
we didn't tell all these [__] to give
up their main sources of revenue yeah we
didn't tell y to stop selling decided to
do that collectively randomly it's like
bro why aren't you selling your [__]
music because you don't have real fans
just like you would sell a t-shirt or
any other product you should be selling
your music too M yeah know I just had to
talk with Queen [__] who was up here
she's on a major label and I was like yo
you got like a vinyl or you know tape or
anything or she's like n actually I just
talk to the label about that I'm like
you got like real fans you'll sell a
thousand of those in a week real fans
like what are we doing like it's it is
crazy though cuz like you said like I
saw somebody it was it you it might have
been you or it might have been uh
somebody had just brought up the
idea
of using
streaming as a commercial for your music
taking it off like a trailer type [__]
like yo you'll see how crazy my is for a
month but then it's gone right now you
got to go buy it which is kind of like
the opposite of what you know I think
people have been doing right yeah I mean
I don't I don't think you have to
neglect the market like leave your [__]
on streaming but allow people who want
to purchase your product to purchase it
from you too you feel me like you don't
have
to you don't have to like revolt against
something and take all your [__] away
cuz you're stealing revenue from
yourself you're not hurting them you're
stealing from CU they're not going
nowhere yeah yeah and and also you're
hurting the opportunity to be discovered
new marketing streaming is a form of
marketing it's like you throw all of
your [__] in a pool and someone may pick
that [__] up to where now they want to
spend money with you they want to go to
your shows they want to buy merch they
want to buy whatever you got to offer
they want to buy stock they want to buy
go- cars like your streaming is just
marketing that you get paid for right
that's fair um so give me uh what's the
update with you man I haven't seen you
uh since I was at your house which was
yeah it was hot outside I just remember
that right it was hot as [__] that was a
great show too it was an amazing show
you had shooter gang Coney out there uh
what was the 16-year-old kid's name you
Molly he was he came up here came up
here yeah he so fire him and his dad
came he six School yep yeah shout out to
Modesto necessary man shout out Merced
Merced Modesto Merced God damn it no not
the same not the same somewhere over
there kind of over there they're not too
far from each
other they might are they are they far
oh
[__] wait noest sh out Merc though wait
Modesto's like by I'm tripping hey man
these little California cities confuse
me but no it was it was a a special day
man it was really dope um your dad was
making food right your mom was getting
me high right um I got to check out just
like your office and your at home studio
and how you kind of schedule your social
media post with your team it was just it
was an inspiring situation because
everybody who I brought with me at some
point in time either artist or you know
my producer he was shooting but he also
was an artist and a a a a beat maker and
engineer so it was just dope for
everybody to see like there's another
way right that I love the backyard shows
cuz you get to see uh so many creatives
in motion not just my team it' be other
[__] filming for their own interviews
and podcast just like it's a pool of
creativity that you get to witness and I
think uh a TV show was there that day
one of the big networks was shooting
that day or what it was CNN CNN CNN yo
yeah it was dope man but what's what so
obviously you've been killing it I've
been seeing a lot of your uh you know
since since then I've watched you on a
bunch of platforms talking about the
movement but what is the latest um
what's going on with L Russell man uh uh
man the compound so much the way right
it's it's a ton of [__] the compound is
something I'm really excited about um we
building like an artist creative and
Wellness Center so it got a a merch
distribution and production facility um
editing Bay editing lab I'm building
like a live venue inside of it for real
intimate shows like a 100 cap low lowkey
[__] um and then we got the content
Studio that we moving over from our shop
and then our old shop we turned turn
into like a creative Hub that our
network will be able to rent and utilize
to do all their creative needs um yeah
[__] just building so people are going
to be able to like if they want to put
music out if they want to get a video
done they could go you could kind of be
onstop shop if I need to get my merch
ran right it's a One-Stop shop but it's
not like um it's for Network like I'm
building infrastructure so when I find
artist like shant's over there someone
knew that we're we're helping cultivate
and she's like incredible so when I find
artists that I really love it's just
like it's easy to integrate them into a
system and we start seeing the following
grow immediately and we just know what
to do so we built all the infrastructure
so we don't have to take someone there
there there there there to get the
result it's crazy because it's I I you
know I I feel like Russ was the OG guy
who was like telling the truth to
rappers but they were like Russ is a
dick right I feel like your message has
been a lot more palatable right
you've inspired I'm sure people you
don't even know you've inspired at this
point man [__] be crazy like big artist
I'm talking about superstars I'm sure
because your content is been digested
Lev labels use my blueprint like if
there's there's there's not too many
officers who don't know who I am and
what I'm doing and telling their and
they all hate on you when I bring listen
can I be honest with you right please
all of these industry guys cuz I bring
your name up all the [__] time they
are hating on you right I'm telling you
they all say the say yeah but but he
ain't got like a like a hit like what's
where's the music and I'm like what like
this happens this I promise
you that a version of that
conversation's happened at least 20
times you know what's crazy too is like
um and I'm talking about people in your
city people in your city I have ton man
I got I know I got tons of songs and
like the the difference is the amount of
money that you're able to put behind the
record like [__] don't understand
[__] be on on label deals and then
contract TRS and I got a million
followers and made millions of dollars
and they haven't but [__] are talking
about oh you ain't got a
hit well you do and you still don't have
what I have you feel me like that [__]
don't be making sense and adding up it's
ego it's ego it's because they can't do
it so they go resort to that I had
someone I was talking to um someone from
a label and I was telling them like
we're about to scale to this next level
he was like man I think if you just kind
of um if you if you work on the music
side y y and I was just like do you hear
the [__] that's blowing up there's not
one artist right now who can make her do
that little dance a family business some
of these songs I've made is like [__]
do you hear what we talk there's no rap
artist who's doing what the [__] I'm
doing and you [__] talking about some
music to me with all the stupid [__] we
hear blowing up it's like y'all in y'all
are insane and the whole industry is
like delusional and Faking It these
[__] don't like these songs that's
being pushed and that's on the radio and
that's getting
they don't listen to them in car they
don't listen to them at home you feel me
but everybody's rallying behind this
[__] and acting like we we we really
it's just weird and everyone has a
job right and that's what I've learned
so all of the people we're talking about
are employed exactly and and it is in
their best interest to keep their
employment status job push whatever
comes across con my autonomy this long
like bro was just saying before walked
out he like man you've been holding out
and it's like I haven't even been
holding out I'm just
unimpressed that's fair I mean I I do
appreciate the transparency that you've
provided to a lot of artists because you
brought up that Rock Nation meeting that
you had and I had had similar meeting
with with Rock Nation didn't get it
quite as far as you but um with my
artist and then I've heard two or three
other people say similar [__] and but
people don't know you could just take
the name Rock Nation out of it cuz I got
homies over there any label that's the
conversation that's happening yeah it is
the terms are always against you like
for the man it's very tough it's very
tough to I've yet to get a deal from a
major that made me feel great I've yet
to get an offer from a how many offers
have you gotten if you had to you know
throw a number out north of north of 15
north of 10 for sure I'd say about 10
seven to 10 I mean that's that's about
all of them
right yeah it's man and they're they're
never
impressive they're never impressive it's
like um I don't know they just don't get
it they they lack the ability to
understand what's coming and what's next
or what's happening and I'm someone who
um they got terms in a contract like man
the last contract we got we was all in
the airport and we was reading through
it and I was putting like te and splash
on game this is what this mean this is
what this mean and it's a lot of [__] in
the contract that's like for a
developing artist and [__] and it's like
y'all don't even take the time and a do
diligence to make a contract based on
who you're doing business with yeah like
you guys didn't even like this is a
standard deal that you're going to offer
10 other people at the very least let me
read something in here that makes you
think like oh they're they're offering L
Russell a deal bro I had a deal that
wanted to take um I think it was 16 or
18% of my entertainment income
and I was just and what does that mean
like how do they even Define that all
money from entertainment so so all money
from entertainment which is which is
crazy but not live show entertain more
so it's like if you end up doing like a
war T yeah right ENT anything you make
in the entertainment field and it's like
I've been making money in entertainment
way before a [__] didn't offered me a
deal so it's like to come and tell
someone you want a percent of that is
just like
unjustifiable for what what you intend
to provide like I've already broken
myself as an artist and this next year
is going to go even crazier I've been
cracking more codes where it's like oh
[__] it's up there's even deals um
where labels will want a piece of if you
start a clothing line while you're
signed yep that they can somehow figure
out was from the music they want a piece
of it this just happened to a friend of
mine who my boy's got a really big
clothing line I mean it's huge he had
signed a deal probably 2012
2013 and there was actually a discussion
that he might have to give up some of
his clothing line yeah and I understand
some of the terms for um an artist that
you take from nothing who like no one
knows this [__] and all of a sudden
everyone those people aren't getting
deals though I under they're getting
three they are are they they just
getting three they're getting it it's a
all encompassing deal because they're
making they're making your brand but to
take a [__] who's coming in who's
already selling out shows and selling
tickets and selling Stu and say oh we
want this it's just like you're [__]
insane you don't even have an artist on
your roster that's at the level that I'm
at but you want those things so there
are situations in which you could see a
360 deal benefic an artist I think a 360
deal is hyper beneficial if you're a
businessman like if you cuz every artist
don't have streaming but some of us I
did half a million on my own shows last
year not counting outside per I do milon
merch so if you're able to leverage
those things exch Capital outside of the
streaming I don't think that's a bad
deal I think that's a great if you go
partner with anyone and you say hey I
love your business I want a percent I'll
put all this money up that's not a bad
thing that's what every [__] startup
company tech company does it's I think
it's a bad thing when it's
like when you don't give a [__] the
amount of funds to actually build it or
the infrastructure and resource actually
build it and you're just going to take
it it's a little it's different it's a
little more it's a little off-putting or
if you if if it's someone who's already
established all this [__] and you're not
giving them the the means of capital to
excel it but you want to take it as just
like bro you got to contribute to get
out of that [__] I heard uh did you ever
see the leor Cohen interview he
explained the 360 deal yeah so he kind
of explained it as if you and I start a
restaurant together and I'm the investor
and and you start taking the sauce
that's popping and selling it at Walmart
do I get a piece of the sauce and I I
understood it from that angle and like
you said like if you're an artist who
doesn't have a cult following doesn't
have a brand doesn't really have
anything going maybe a little Tik talk
moment maybe it is worth it it makes so
much sense because in the machine you'll
get on the other side of that deal
eventually and that it'll help you
recuit faster mhm it'll help cuz product
SS way faster than music right so you'll
be able to recoup and be out your
situation way faster if it aligns like I
said if someone's helping you build all
those revenues like if you don't have a
merch business going and someone says oh
I I'll help you make a million dollars
in merch yeah I think they should have a
percent yeah if you that [__] standard
for every [__] that comes in this
office you just offer it to him it's
like like some of my issues with some of
the deals I got is like I'll give a
proposal and they ask what I want and
I'll get the contract back and it's a
bunch of [__] that we didn't even
discuss it's like you don't you don't
just throw something in a [__] contract
without it's like a political Bill like
they be like yo they be toow so much
[__] into these bills that are supposed
to be about something else and you like
really reading like wait what we're
[__] what right no that's some real
[__] it's crazy because um I do feel
like you know if there's anybody who can
kind of lead a real change in
Renaissance into how this is thought of
um I think it's you man cuz I've SE I've
seeing it I saw Curtis King post his
[__] from even what is even so even is a
uh an all- incompetent platform
eventually it's going to grow to artist
Hub where are part of it or you yeah I
have Equity okay so you have equity and
even I've been seeing people post their
the very first launch of Spotify Recaps
this what I did
hilarious yeah man even is an all-
incompetent platform for artists like we
just give artists the ability to
monetize and sell their music if they
don't have their own situation some some
artists don't have a Shopify setup or or
just want to have a website and all that
[__] and even makes it easy for the fans
to come support and buy your music
directly from you what's the play so my
whole thing with the with the third
party [__] right is we're so conditioned
to play music on certain apps so if I
buy an album on
even it's it's set up just like Spotify
it's an inapp streamer so it's so I'll
download the even app on my phone right
so if I
based it's web based so it's not so
that's what y got to figure out
eventually it get that cuz that's that
for as a fan for Fan Experience purposes
right that's what you want you want to
be able to be like oh cool I got my even
library of all the [__] I've supported
yeah definitely I want and I believe he
built a web base based off like data
that people were still kind of going
online for specific the thing and it's
like even was really built from the dirt
a year ago like I just did the very
first launch last year when I did 000 on
album that was the first anybody's heard
of it in existence and I campaigned the
whole proud to pay offer like this [__]
was built from the dirt and in one year
we've gotten omaran and dizzy RS and a
bunch of major labels are on board and
now like the majors are going to even so
they can run their upcoming artist I
wonder like uh cuz yeah I wish I feel
like if I was an upand cominging artist
I would want to have that option like is
that we get worked into my deal where
like yo if I want to be able to you guys
might get a cut of this but right I want
to be able to sell my [__] right for
maybe the first week well I mean a lot
of artists see when you going into the
major system it's so different cuz it's
very hard to sell music that you don't
own it
is straight up very hard yeah you got to
ask permission
right yo um can you give me some insight
on like uh how
influential nipy has been cuz nipy was
kind of the first guy to do the pr the
pay pioner in so many ways nipy is the
reason I decided to start doing proud to
pay and I feel like I revolutionized it
another tier by doing offer based so I
started with proud to pay I was riding
my bike and I was like thinking about
nip $100 album and I was like man how
can I do this but in a way that's
conducive to my people CU I didn't know
too many [__] who would pay 100 for an
album so I was like I'm just going to
let [__] pay whatever because if I
make $1 over Z then I won right so I
started doing pay what you want and I
and I end up doing a live show that was
pay what you want and I made less than I
projected but I noticed that people
don't want to pay a certain amount at
the door because there hella people
around so typically some [__] would
give me a rack a 100 but you don't want
to do that at the door with people
behind you so I I end up creating offer
base when I start doing my backyard I
was like let's start doing offer based
because I can't I can't set a ticket
price on this experience like you came
to the backyard we had shows with s
there and different people come out so
it's like how can I right man I can't
say this a $20 ticket a $5 ticket $30
none of that makes sense to me so I'm
like you tell me what what you think
this experience is worth and all I could
do is say yes or no for this one you
feel me and um was it hard to figure out
the back end of the offer based thing
cuz I've never seen like any website
offer something where you no it was new
with the technology was completely new
like I got what my partner e Brea he
created a a ticketing site called W TBA
that just sold regular tickets and when
I came I was like man I got this idea I
need to build a tech behind it so I
could do my shows a certain way and we
just started this last year like I said
I did half a million on what's TBA offer
Bas shows last year I think that's the
future if you're smart man it's the
present and a going for exactly you
especially when you um when you have a
real live show and a real live
experience and something like me where
you get to holl at me and talk to me and
I'm around like when you know what it
eventually it gets to the point where
people stop offering you L like people
are just like I know what I'm getting
and I know what this [__] is worth and
what it means to me yeah like if um
certain artists who are like a certain
level end up taking that and running
with it it's going man clean up clean up
I even think of like a guy like you know
I always you you always hear a couple of
names Drake Kendrick like if they ever
decided to go independent it would break
the music industan up like if Drake
decided to be like clean up [__] the
labels are pissing their pants he would
break the music industry forever yeah I
mean right now there's a lot of slow
work towards that but that's they know
that which is why they're okay running
him h a quarter billion and pl because
they know they know like he's he's he's
responsible for saving the industry at a
at a specific time time so they know
yeah like and and I think of guys like
the weekend like the weekend's team his
infrastructure that isn't the label just
his team is so on point I'm like yo at
what point can the label do anything but
write you a [__] check that and
that's eventually it gets to that point
and I honestly and truly feel like I'm
getting to that point now like after
this run I'm about to have in
2024 at this point there's not much they
could do but it's even now the offers I
is like y'all got to you can only run a
Check and which you should want to when
you see a [__] already got a business
completely established and built all you
want to do is get a cut cuz you don't
have to do nothing it's like I came to
you and said oh you got a pizza spot let
me just give you some bread and give me
a percent every month that's a win
definitely don't have a pizza spot uh
officially publicly but maybe soon yeah
it be announced on my Instagram that was
like a random you know I do have a
nightclub that's very successful in
scottd yeah I se that yeah shout out to
uh my business partners perfect example
hey man we tried to get people to invest
it was it's just three of us and uh
everybody who said no within the first
month were like hey can we get in and
I'm like [__]
no right cardi B and Meek Mill and
everybody's like yo man look if you guys
still need a second phase of money I'm
like no we're good now like everybody
don't see it everybody don't see it and
and that is the main thing I think that
you're a testament of bro is cuz these
conversations I'm telling you about that
I've had with people right they don't
see it and they don't get it and they're
they're oblivious to like all you got to
do is see it that's all and people are
you know if you believe in what you're
doing and you're sure of it and you got
good people around you who aren't yes
men [__] if somebody who don't like [__]
[__] with with with some a anr things
[__] with some label executive things
like make them see your vision it be
tough it' be
and that's easier said than done right
that's easier said than done man it's
tough to to to stay down cuz you get
offered these sums and you want to go
but it man you really got to stick to
like and you got to have a workout other
thing is Major label might be for you if
you're lazy yeah I think the ma your
work ethic is insane I think the majors
are necessary because there there are
some artists that are just insanely
talented but they don't have the um the
care or desire to do all the other [__]
to make sure the world I think the
labels are necessary even for a [__]
like me like if we find the right label
with the right deal I'm gone cuz I'm
already gone it's like I'm not on the
major and I'm on every major platform
and [__] know it's got to be the right
deal though that's it what up y'all
bootleg Kev here shout out to our family
at Imperial extraction listen right now
oh a free two G free roll of that zah of
that loud of that gas can get right to
your door delivered for free now this is
what's dope about uh Imperial let me
tell you man the thing about Imperial is
they got 16 years of experience when it
comes to this West Coast cannabis space
and recently they just got into the hemp
scene now what is the hemp scene that
means uh that it's it's legal it's going
to get delivered right to your door
federally legal it ships to your door no
issues uh and this is what also is dope
about it it's still going to get you
high it's going to get you blown just
like that uh traditional cannabis it's
that
thca um look they got so much stuff
going on um this is the thcp enhanced
live resin you can get your carts there
they got all the flavors boom boom most
importantly whatever you do Imperial uh
make sure you go to their website
because uh look Imperial extraction.
comom if you go to that website and you
use that promo code bootle you're going
to get hooked up with a free 2 G
pre-roll right now Imperial extraction.
comom get yourself I've been smoking
these for uh about three weeks now and
man I love them and um they definitely
get me elevated man and and this is
what's dope about these let me show yall
just real quick if you guys don't know
um Imperial extraction let's pop one
open because this is what's getting
delivered to your house for free
remember Imperial extraction. comom
promo code bootle
checkout look at that thing man it's a 2
G pre-roll with the glass tip premium
thca and it's got the diamond infused uh
joints in here you bust this thing open
there's little diamonds in there bro
it's crazy all right it comes with one
and a half grams of that top shelf flour
half a gram of the pure thca diamonds
and uh it's free yeah so uh go to the
promo code bootleg at Imperial
extraction. comom and trust me when I
say you will not regret it shout out to
Imperial extraction also want to give a
shout out to our good Folks at Blue chw
that's right salute to the family at
blueo make sure you head on over to
blue.com use that promo code bootleg
right now if you don't know blue Chu is
where it's at they're getting you
situated real nicely when it comes to
your penis your Johnson your [__] oh
that's a that's a weird way to who says
[__] I don't know nonetheless if you're
dealing with the rectile dysfunction if
you're dealing with a little anxiety
little stress and you're not up to par
when it comes to Performance look you
need to put your best step forward when
it comes to your dick game you know what
I'm saying so what you need to do is go
to uh blue.com use the promo code
bootleg right now they're going to give
you a month supply for free now if
you're watching this you don't know
about blueo Let Me Explain same exact
active ingredient as Viagra and Calis in
a chewable form deliver to your door
discreetly yes no doctor's appointments
uh none of that it's all online you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in an office and waiting to go
get your dick pills no listen by the way
these aren't dick pills these are this
is a chewable you know what I'm saying
let's just be clear there's a difference
this is much better um bluechew.com
promo code bootleg month supply for free
delivered to your door
discreetly all online it's what we're
doing man same active ingredients
viagran seis man get your dick right all
right let's get back to the interview
you did do a oneoff with Russ yeah which
I thought was awesome uh we talked about
this a bit in the Vlog we did when I
went to your house um for people who
don't know who didn't see that Vlog you
did a one one deal album with Russ you
were still dropping tons and tons and
tons cuz Russ is the most artist
friendly guy ever and he just wanted to
be down you know yeah um but he had gone
on his tour and he had offered you to
come and open on the tour and you turned
that down yeah most people would hear
that I think me and hovain talked about
it when it happened God Rest hovain soul
rest in peace to my brother um most
people would love to go on a tour with
Russ and open cuz he was doing like
Arenas and like amphitheaters and stuff
at that moment cuz this was two three
years ago 2021 so yeah so this was two
years ago22 yeah this was the sh the
snow globe album yeah um most people
would jump at that uh opportunity I know
why you didn't do it I kind of want you
to explain cuz you've built so much
since then but I want you to explain why
you passed on that opportunity man it
would have took me away from home and I
was building in
something I really really really
believed in at home and I knew that yeah
you know and I knew the opportunity to
go on tour with circle back and I didn't
um I didn't I didn't really want to go
on tour and get a salary like I could go
do shows and make my own paper so I
really just wanted to stay home and
build and I end up building the backyard
residency in the perlet and that [__]
end up making me I mean 10x what I would
have generated on that tour and new fans
new me new everything you feel me so I'm
I'm happy I stayed home it was like yeah
cuz you would have got new fans that way
but you I don't know if you would have
gotten the amount of like super engaged
fans that you got by just doing your own
the cultural like it it just the
backyard is different you know like the
backyard is different and what what I'm
doing in terms of culture like you going
my comments and you see the Buster
Rhymes and the ogs in there because they
know what's up like we ain't seen Hip
Hop look like this in a minute and and I
think one of the last times you might as
saw it looked like this probably was in
your area I feel like when I think of
independent [__] I think of Texas I
think of No Limit and I think of the bay
out the trunk you know saying for sure
uh is your
house because this is your your family's
house this is the house that you know
you grew up in at what point in time
does your Fame does your home become
inhabitable because of how popular you
are cuz for people who don't know your
house is in it's in a normal
neighborhood yeah there's no like crazy
there's no security there's it's just
your house right this is a normal house
that you grew up Ino California there's
stage in the backyard there I mean your
parents are there you got to get to a
point where is it a you're going to end
up moving out of the house or getting
the parents out of there renting it out
or has it not gotten there yet I doubt
I mean we don't know how big it's going
to be yet Drake hasn't came to the
backyard just yet you know when Drake
and right now as of right now no we good
man my house is protected and it's like
I'm really from where I'm from like this
is my home I walk every day around the
block and everybody like I'm from there
I I hoop there I play tennis my daughter
we we like I'm I'm home no I no I get it
I get it but like again if once you get
to a certain point you're just going to
have random people flying to the Bay
being like yo let's go drive by the
Russell's house and see yeah yeah we had
a [__] come in uh from Buffalo and it
was his first time ever been on the
plane and he was like man I just had to
come see it and see if it was real so
yeah it's like did he knock on the door
no he just kind of drove p and said I
think he ended up messaging us cuz he
had brought like some merch and I went
outside and I holled at him and I was
like man this isn't okay but I [__] with
you when I see I get it I understand
like man I I'm a human and I know how it
feel to have somebody that really ch
change your light like this man was in
his 30s and it was his first time ever
getting on a flight cuz he was like I
have to go to that backyard [__] crazy
flight Buffalo there's no direct flight
don't there's no direct flight you had a
layover you feel me so I I understand
that that energy and when I was growing
up in a V I never seen nobody famous
like I never seen anyone who made it
where I was like ah I get to witness you
know I didn't I didn't get that
experience so when I be mobing around
outside like I get it I understand Crocs
endorsement happened yet it's on the way
they got it man it's on the way are you
still hanging on the Android you are huh
yeah come on man this guy it's on the
way this guy hey man it's on the way yo
and Samsung [__] take care of this
guy right he's got the green bubbles all
day right is real so I wanted to ask you
cuz um there I I'd love to see a couple
of things one I think we have a mutual
friend who I talked to today one of my
closest friends in the music industry
Simba who I love dearly and um you know
he's he's he's in the major label
machine you know as he is um uh so I
don't know how easy or hard or difficult
it is for you guys to drop a real
project together um but I've heard that
being floated around I feel like when I
think about the two guys not just in the
bay I'm talking about just music period
where I'm just like man we're in good
hands it's you and him at the top of
that list was that something you guys
talked about or is that something that
not really um not really we don't need
me and Simba um like hell of a feeling
is like our first song together like we
worked on some [__] prior but it wasn't
nothing we both loved but hell of a
feeling was our first track together we
never really anytime we link we don't do
music like we really hang and chop it up
where it come to the backyard and we rap
like man that's the dope thing about
like bro I [__] with [__] you got to be
human with me like like con is one of my
my best friends and it's like we come we
don't even do music together we just rap
and hang and chill and talk about life I
think Simba 2 has got an understanding
of a lot of
things out like that are at a high level
that most artists don't in terms of like
branding in terms of like how he speaks
in terms of like when he goes on
platforms I think he sometimes he'll
approach an interview like it's an album
yeah Simba Simba's Simba's uh smarter
than a lot of um
a lot of the [__] in the game like
he's just more strategic and calculated
he understands what about you doing an
album Nothing But pilo beats it's coming
we are me me and pilo been talking about
that for the past two years so yeah
that's that has to happen right cuz dog
the listen you you and you over just
pilo beats for a whole project right and
then [__] that's going to be a moment
too for the for the for the home team
man and that'll shut up some of the uh
the you know the Bay Area Gatekeepers
get that won't even shut them up there's
nothing that can shut them up it's like
I made baggage claim in the whole world
that [__] was going viral for months T
20 like that nothing to shut them up you
know that just doesn't happen I've
reached a million followers
independently and I've never bought a
follower that's beautiful there is
nothing that could shut these people up
cuz they don't know nothing I don't buy
streams everything I have organic
authentic growth are you still um so for
people who don't know who maybe are just
heard of you watching this you have a a
situation with your albums where well
one what I love that you do is you take
care of your team so if someone shoots a
video if you do a a full project with
you know your producer uh you're cutting
the team in on the on the on the equity
on the album right um are you still
doing that in terms of like fans being
able to say man I want to get a cut sell
stock every month and is that stock walk
me behind the business behind that
because um for people who don't know
there's a there is a platform that's
called Dr kid right where you're able to
upload your music uh and then split the
music which is an easy way for you to
pay featured artists writers producers
management whatever right so are you
Distributing the stock it gets purchased
and then do you go in on is it Dro kid I
don't use drro kid anymore like the um
the technical capability wasn't there
for the level that I was doing it at so
I currently use command shift Nvidia and
I just start I just start rocking with
two loss as well I like they they're
back in yeah I heard video is dope yeah
video is great command shift's great I
and these are drro companies that are
similar to like toon C these are
distribution companies and they have the
same type of Technology but at a larger
scale ter that that been my thing like
man there's other dealings that we were
trying to do but it didn't align cuz
they didn't have a split system and to
me is like if I can't split the money
and control my own back end and see
where my [__] going and when I'm going
to pay somebody that's a red flag it
just doesn't it's also if you don't have
the split system set up and you're a Dro
company I mean how I mean toor had to do
it right eventually right Tom didn't do
it for a long time they didn't for a
long time they had to do it they
understood that's like well [__] I mean
shout out the kid they change the game
for when you're D you don't have one
you're encouraging people to steal money
from other collaborators and artists
yeah because you might not even want to
do it on purpose especially because
there's different angles of that but
let's say you're an artist just the idea
of like maybe you have management that's
supposed to handle the splits and you
know it's it's just things get lost in
the wind if you could just set up the
splits and it's just locked in man I
just started using two losses portal
recently and I got to go holler at them
because they got it set up to where you
submit the release then you enter the
split and I'm just going to tell them
the same thing like you're going to
encourage people to be able to monetize
their art before they start paying their
collaborators like you not you shouldn't
be able to submit the release until
everybody is kind of accounted for and
because not not you not me but a lot of
artists A lot of people it's like human
nature that like once you see that money
come in you're like he Bo it's tough but
what I'm saying is like if you just set
up the splits from the jump then
whatever money you're getting is the
money you're getting that's all you need
exactly and then you're like cool you
know what I mean but if you get the
whole pie and you're like yeah you know
some people are inclined to be a little
little cheaper right right naturally
that's a human thing um you don't do
necessarily touring you do shows yeah I
do one all show sometimes you'll just
pop up and be like I have a show today
at 2m. man that's special that's what's
special about this year coming up
because I'm doing um touring in a
non-traditional way I'm doing
residencies in different cities so
during the you know spring and winter we
going to be in venues and then when the
summer come I'm finding different
backyards in each of these cities where
we can do our thing still any uh any La
uh La is on the list LA is on the list
LA is on the list so when you're going
to do a residency in a city how many
shows in the year how many shows per
City let's say la what do we do four
five three yeah like six six okay y you
just need to find a spot yep I like that
this is the way people [__] I mean like
shout out the promoters but why would
you pay a promoter if you could promote
yourself just rent the venue cuz a lot
of [__] can't promote themselves and a
lot of [__] don't eat even promote
their own shows this is true they
they're really worried about social
media aesthetic right they they don't
want to look a certain way hey bro that
is the biggest pet peeve I have with
artists when they're so worried about
the aesthetic of how their page looks
that they won't even promote their own
[__] right that happens and it just kind
of tell it's like bro you probably don't
love what you
made like if you don't want to tell
people hey I made this [__] you probably
don't really enjoy what you made hey um
you've you have a great team um you guys
have come up with a system in terms
of the way you will repurpose content
yeah like if you go do an interview if
you go you know this will be repurposed
the time right hey you see your CLP for
the next six seven months um whether
it's a freestyle or you know you guys
shoot a backyard performance that ends
up you know living on on your IG on on
YouTube shorts whatever but you you guys
have a real uh on-purpose method of how
you schedule your post every
day what kind of post it is what time of
day you post break that down because I I
think if people saw the way you run your
content it's very inspiring and I think
you just don't have to be L like if
you're not lazy like there's like you
just got to keep on throwing shots into
the algorithm right like man we're just
cating a channel so I remember when we
first started um I had a bunch of live
sessions already cuz we used to do the
good company live session so I was
posting hell of those and then I started
doing interviews so I'm like all right
now we need to integrate interviews and
then we started doing shows and let's
let's integrate show footage and then
like now we'll have like real life
moments like I'm just hooping like the
other day I shot the ball from the roof
and it's like okay that's integrate
those four different types of content so
you can see me four times a day in a
different way so you're able to become a
fan and different facet and you know
posting every few hours it's just like
if you have it and we toned it back like
we used to have so much and me and tia
sat and I was like all right now let's
let's let's hone it down let's only post
the pieces that we like man this this
made feel good right and then we got to
that point it was like okay now let's
lock it down even more only post the one
that we look at each other certain point
in time was it four or five times a day
yeah like six five six because I do
think like there's a couple of things
like like everyone will have an excuse
why they don't have content to shoot um
and and I don't I don't buy it anymore
CU I got homies who are making six
figures in their life off of their phone
off of whatever app just chilling but
you do have you do have a team you have
t who help you you have a team at this
point but it wasn't always like that
right but for you what is like the
Practical solution for an artist who has
2,000 monthly listeners who just is
putting out records trying to
follow you know I think a lot of artists
will see the path you take the path Russ
takes the path that a lot of artists
take in terms of throwing up shots
throwing up shots and they kind of feel
like they're it's just not working at a
certain point in time the music has to
be good right people have to buy into
you at a certain point in time and there
has to be that be my thing with the
industry when [__] be talking about
all the hit in the music cuz I'm like
you think I got to a million followers
organically if I don't have you think
these [__] come to my backyard
s anding every lyric without they don't
know the lyrics to your artist s we
don't know the [__] he
saying but I was going to say the
practicality of like that struggling up
and cominging artist
who when they think of content it breaks
their brain when they think of like
because a lot of people you have to be
good at Instagram you have to be good at
like like for whatever reason like
people can respect it or not respect it
it's a talent to like really understand
how to cut up a piece of content how you
know for some there's so many different
routes you could take though I was
telling T the other day I love boozy and
Lil Duvall and like Charleston white cuz
they don't do content in a traditional
way it's just them being themselves
Gilly is one of those where he has
content but he's also a lot of his posst
is just him it's just him pulling his
phone out screaming about the Eagles in
front of a
TV if you don't have the ethic to figure
it out it's just not for you just keep
making excuses and complaining it's just
not for you if anybody who man there's
so many you can go shoot visualizers
we've had visualizers go viral a
visualizer is like a music video but
short form basically I write out a whole
music video treatment and I just pick
one scene and be like all right let's
shoot this and put the song on it that
[__] Cali Bon went viral a few times
outstanding doing numbers do those have
you seen this guy anise yeah y he's so
good at
I mean I've seen him promote the same
song for like over a year in different
ways he might be sitting at a tennis
court singing a song he might be on the
bro if you take one song and you do a
live Rec a live performance one with
your instrumental one with a guitarist
one with a Pianist you got three
different pieces of content and one
might go then you can start doing
specialty [__] go outside and record
your [__] do it live like it's just so
many things you could do for a [__] to
be like I don't know what to do is like
you're not trying you're not trying and
you're scared of how not going to work
that too right people are scared well
what happens if I throw something up and
it makes me look crazy cuz cuz social
media is transparency so if you throw
something up and it don't do well people
will see and your insecurities your
insecurities will prevent you from from
getting over that hump you got to do it
failure is data yeah you're not going to
make every single shot you take mhm
bootle Kev here hey shout out to King
pom man we want to show them some love
uh listen I've been I feel like
enlightened recently uh since we've been
working with King pom man the cleanest
smoke organic all natural no tobacco and
this is what's dope about King pom is um
they have these Turpin infused tips and
what I love about them is whatever
flavor you're into like these are the
red rain energy drink flavors on big
energy drink guy right so you stuff what
you need in these bad
boys hit that tip you're going to get
hit with a nice shock of flavor boom
that's the uh pink lemonade also these
are the natural boys but I'm going to
show you what it looks like rolled up
all right let's take a peek in here we
got the king palom boys
here this what we're doing all right now
if you go to King pom.com it is the
holiday season you want to take care of
somebody you love you want to take care
of yourself you deserve to be taken care
of yo 50% off right now use that promo
code bootleg it's either 50 or 40% [__]
probably should know that I think it's
50 though either way it's 50 or 40
bootleg king pom.com or you know go to
7-Eleven they got them uh at there uh
any of your smoke shops in your hood
whatever it is wherever you're at pull
up to your smoke shop get you some King
pal one more time organic flavor no
tobacco it's lit also can we show some
love to our family at harden man shout
out to harden man look if you're in
Vegas you got to pull up you got to say
take me to harden right now I need to go
go to harden they're going to take you
they're going to get you situated Harden
Las Vegas the best cannabis uh
dispensary I've ever walked into in my
life the most craziest selection of
Premium cannabis in the entire world I
mean that place smells like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Hardin Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
Las vegas.com and when you're in Vegas
make make sure you pull up to harden
baby and I always tell people too you
can upload new re like you could
re-upload reels but not have it on your
feed just throw it back into the system
right so it pops up um so music- wise I
we know what you're doing in in the New
Year how I mean you're always working on
new albums they're coming out all the
time what's what's what's uh what's
coming next man we got a project with
link up coming I'm going to drop before
the year close that'll be album Number
30 and then I just did some incredible
songs with this producer named Mike G um
from Chicago that [__] coming I got [__]
with that I'm always making music like
that that's my passion I love to make
music so I don't think I'm ever not GNA
be
dropping would you ever sell your
catalog like people are selling their
catalogs I wouldn't it's a thing you
know people are getting bags yeah no
people do um I personally wouldn't would
you ever sell a piece of it for the
right price no I license it though but I
wouldn't I
wouldn't like say some i' rather just
build new homes for people like and
that's been something I've been running
into with like trying to do deals with
labels or dros cuz they all want your
catalog and I'm like no I spent years
building my own [__] and marketing
putting my own money you're not getting
my catalog but I will build new homes
with you we could do 25 30 50 new things
but you're not going to get all the work
SP doing for the last four years yeah
yeah yeah that's real so that is
something and for you it's just a matter
of like if you ever were to go down that
major label rabbit hole it's got to be
the right deal it's got to be a fair
deal it's got I notic um I don't I
wouldn't sell my catalog either cuz I
own my catalog I know there's a lot of
artists that do sell their catalog and
they publishing they only own a Slither
a a portion of it so it's like I mean
yeah I'd sell 10% of something but I own
I own my entire do you do do you do song
trust or where where's your Pub through
do you do any I do I use Cobalt now but
I started with s trust you know and
everybody could go get a song trust they
were doing my first publishing admin I'm
with ASAP and then s trust did my
Administration and I end up doing a a
deal with Cobalt last year oh that's
fire right and they man they admin they
[__] I like just going into they portal
and looking at the numbers and how far
that [__] reach it's it's incredible you
somehow have broken through a ceiling
that at times as a barrier artist Fe
feels impossible to penetrate bro it's a
new peak in terms of like the media you
do the attention you're getting there's
so many Bay Area artists that I love
that are my friends that we love that
we're fans of but you know what I mean
it all even La has that ceiling maybe
it's a little you know LA's LA but there
always feels like in the bay you know
there's a there's so many dope artists
that you kind of have to be from like a
part of the country to know about you
know right and and um I think it's the
level of investment um and marketing
that we're willing to put into our work
um I haven't met too many artists um
from the region
who does content in the way that we do
content or spend like what I spend on
ads and marketing and on seeding like
what I spend having a tour and invest
and building the live show building the
venue like it's
just the the lack of infrastructure like
we all of our blueprints is independent
right and and that Independence has
always had some sort of ceilling when it
comes to like mainstream we don't get
the same media and the same looks
like man [__] just did you have to
really invest like you have to invest
the same way major would like I spend
when I get contracts their marketing
budgets already spent that [__] you feel
me it's like you're not giving me
nothing I haven't done for myself but a
lot of artists Indie coming up they're
not willing to to spend that amount or
put their money where it needs to go you
feel put they buy a
belt right and that's that's all artists
not even Universal to the region [__]
are buy drugs that's period it's like yo
fam yeah the amount produc amount a
[__] spend on drugs in a month if you
put that [__] into ads and seeding
you'll probably grow two three the most
frustrating [__] is cuz you know I
manage producers and and we'll do like
you know for examp example Cyrus over
here recently he did a uh he mixed and
mastered a record right for a friend who
remain nameless now this friend that
remain nameless he's a good friend this
guy flaunts you know um like he's got
you know he's doing really well
ah but for whatever reason could not
Square my man up I won't say how much he
charged him but he charged him an
extremely low amount because he's a
friend but for whatever reason Bo and to
me this happens with producers
videographers photographers it's like
fam if you could go buy the chunky ugly
Balenciaga shoes you could pay for the
beat bro if you could sit in a picture
like this with the racks you could break
a [__] break some bread to your video
break [__] off who helped step your
visuals up you could break a [__] off
who helped n reinvest in your
craft but I feel like those things have
to be taught my pots wasn't a hustler
who invested in his craft and
taught was [__] you feel me like you
have to be taught those things a lot of
[__] get money and they're never talk
that's your first time having money like
if you're artist from the Block and you
come out [__] this your first time
having paper that [__] change you and
make you feel different you don't have
the awareness and information necessary
to go do all that [__] especially if you
end up going to a label like man if some
[__] be so [__] up cuz they assigned
really early and then once they get out
of that label it's like you stuck cuz
you didn't really build any
infrastructure and then you didn't sit
down with the people to get the
information so you didn't use your
advance in a way that could set up
something post label right and and it's
like it's not an easy thing to do like
you have to know where the Bro still to
this day like I just recently found out
some new [__] with the ass and we've
been well I Facebook Instagram Tik Tok
Tik Tok yeah hey shout out to Tik you
know what's crazy is there on the
content Creator aspect like people will
frown on Facebook and Snapchat cuz they
think the [__] is out bro they pay
better Snapchat pays I have a Snapchat
show now where they just take our
interview Clips a guy in the UK H and uh
bro it pays way better than YouTube
Snapchat right who I [__] bro I don't
have I haven't had Snapchat on my phone
in 40 years right Facebook too they like
we F to stop paying that
[__]
he's like I actively use Snapchat every
day but for you are you are you noticing
so you're noticing the cuz cuz for a
while there bang for your buck wise
Facebook was still great um are you so
you're noticing that you could do Tik
Tok ads man I think all of them are
great in terms of ads bang for your buck
like like here let me show you I look at
this [__]
um I like to point out I did shame him
but I also have an Android I have I have
both I have have both this one has a pen
I can sign things with right what is
that a s23 I got sitting on here
something so look this is the past seven
days right this on Tik Tok 700,000 views
wow 4,000 followers 74,000 likes right
you hit the promote that's that's the
past seven days right so I go to the
dashboard spent
4,200 at on 700,000 views 4,000 new
followers right so 4,000 new followers
off of Ian that's a great turn 4,000
followers I spend four grand right out
of these 4,000 people if throughout the
year I just get them to spend $50 with
me I made 200k if you follow L Russell
and become a fan the least you going to
spend with a [__] is 25 so no matter
what I'm I'm paying ating that money cuz
those new fans are coming in they're
going they're going to break bread with
you I could sell a gold card two gold
cards a month and I made back my ad
spend what is the the the GO card that
you're talking about yeah so go cards I
launched uh at the end 2021 and it's
basically like the first artist
membership subscription if you got a
gold card you can come to any L Russell
show that I throw for free so you get in
how much how much is a go card like a
rack it's offer based oh offer based so
like somebody can you tell us the most
You' the most I've gotten for a gold
card fire Rax that's great yeah
yeah right and it's like that's a
lifetime of shows I'm going to be doing
Arenas in a year
Years bro [__] who got go cards they
like I'm out here you feel me like the
backyard shows I do so many a year
goldart members get to come for it's a
like the backyard shows sell out you
can't get in if you got a goldart you
ain't even got to think about when I
start the LA residency any City I'm in
if you have one you in there and you
don't have to worry about nothing it
come with a plus one like bro I love
that and you get random shares and songs
like I just go through the list
sometimes when I drop albums and send
percentages to just random [__] who
bought gold cards from me has there been
an artist that has reached out to you
for some advice that is somebody who
people would think you maybe you know
not a peer somebody who's you know
you've seen a lot of these big big
rappers Superstar rappers complaining
about their situations like a me Mill
like a YG like has anybody ever reached
out to you just in the DMS and been like
man like showing showing you some love
or not really any major
not really any major artist has really
tapped into to be like yo could you
assist with this but a lot of the Indies
coming up Tapp in and I mean
like yeah not not really too many of the
major guys but some of the people coming
out of the major system that's having to
go back in Indie and [__] like that like
man I feel like the major artists are
like hyper prideful anyway like say when
you mention probably very they're
probably very paranoid was going to
screenshot a [__] DM end up on
academics right whatever it is um I was
going to ask you uh um for you what is
if if somebody is wanting to get
involved on even right what in what
would be your advice on how the roll out
should go down should it be dsps even
even at the same time do you do even
first do you I mean I know you know
there not a one- siiz fits all but if if
based on what you've experien me
personally I like to do even first and I
like to package my music with perks okay
so like if you buy albums for I do all
offer bait you can pay whatever you want
but I tear it out so if you pay between
a certain amount that might come with a
this if you pay this amount it might
come with a CD if you pay this amount it
might come with a vinyl you pay this it
might come with a go-kart like I like to
give people an incentive to support me
but yeah I like to go to even first
before it even how long will you have it
exclusively on even before like a week
or two weeks okay that's dope shout out
to uh yo you know who's doing a great
job selling their music and treating it
like art pieces is do you know who M
Mami is so he's a guy who dropped he
dropped an album he's like OG Buffalo
Griselda guy he dropped an I don't even
know if he's from Buffalo but um he
treats his albums like art pieces bro so
like you have to buy the vinyl but
there's only like a thousand of them and
like that's it that's and and and but
but some of these vinyls go for like
that's a wave I'm about to go to so two
chains did a most expensive [__] um you
know he has that show and he met with
some vinyl collectors and this guy
pulled out this makami album I think
that was going for like 10 grand or
something and and it's crazy because you
you hadn't heard of him and two chains
hadn't heard of him and the only reason
I had heard of him is cuz he dropped a
dope album Griselda a couple years ago
um but then I started to dive into like
his business model he doesn't have an
Instagram he only has he has a fan page
that like he don't run right but it's
this small community where like the
music is so exclusive and the vinyl is
so extravagant right it looks so
beautiful and it's like it's and he's
killing it I [__] with that wave like
I'm I'm about to move to that point too
like doing like you know I used to sell
microphones after I do a big show I sign
the microphone and I Ox it off to the
fans and I'm microphones for a crazy
amount and I I just like giving the fans
collectible thing like we got Omaha
cassette collectible things cuz I know
I'm going to be as big as wherever the
[__] is the biggest one day and now they
get to make p off some [__] that they
got for supporting early like man when
when the streaming side really kicked
and everyone who got percentages and
royalties in our [__] they're going to
be like oh [__]
man have you ever uh had any uh chats
with with uh a dude named casy white boy
rapper casy used to be on cash money
cash money casy no I haven't I haven't H
he's doing a really good job of building
up his independ but he's he's just did
the second version of his $100 mixtape
and the first time he made 100 Grand in
a day you know and he's and he's doing
the second one and can't beat it
especially if you got a dedicated Die
Hard following it's like people want to
support you're going to get this super
[__] sick you're going to get it on
CD but you're also going to get like
this extravagant uh I think the first
time you did a cool USB but you know if
you're sitting on music his his whole
thing is like I don't know where these
songs are going to go because I record
so much but they're all fire so here's
30 records for
$100 once they're sold out they're
[__] sold out that's hard and all of
his fans from the first time honored not
uploading any of
them
because he's like yo people could upload
them on YouTube if they want but like
I'm asking everybody not to and they
still haven't hit the internet [__] so
it's dope man well [__] I'm I'm super
proud of you bro it's dope to see
everything everything you're doing
Mutual I think you're uh you know like I
said bro I think you're kind of changing
you're changing the game bro I feel like
you caught me at the same time I caught
you going into like that Indie grind and
building that phase and it's been dope
to see the parallel and you still you
that's the beautiful part like I could
still text a call or I you hit me like
four hours ago like I just landed in La
was do something I'm like I I was so far
away I was like I'll make it happen come
on yeah so listen man uh go support
everything this guy does uh there's so
many ways they can support you whichever
way you find that works the best for you
go do that if it's streaming if it's
even if it's through a live show if it
whatever works for you do that you uh
real quick I want you to give some game
to upand cominging producers cuz you do
work closely with certain producers to's
here who's from Portland um what would
be the game you'd give to a producer
who's got heat but just doesn't I mean
the producer game to me is as as an
outsider was kind of an ins it's just a
discouraging right thing it's almost
like being a graphic designer or a
photographer it's like [__] man like
super underappreciated you're underpaid
people take advantage of you there's
there's people who chase placement
there's the YouTube Type Beat there's
but if you were a producer what would be
the game you would give a producer to
attack the music industry from your
approach work horizontally and build
something don't chase anything just work
horizont find the [__] you love that's
around you that's in your city and just
go build with them and talk about the
splits and just get your royalties
eventually you get to a point where you
got 60 70 80 songs all giving you this
percentage coming in and you getting
your publishing and you don't have to go
rely on the industry to get you a bag or
one of those artists you work with that
you believe in is going to blow up and
you're going to benefit from that
whether they take care of you or not
you're going to a rising tide lifts all
boats I mean if you you look at a lot of
the bigname guys they started with one
person mustered with YG you know what
I'm saying like even the the homie 6
with uh with logic like there's and
that's all you got to do like find
someone you love and just pour R to him
man man to and told been working since
2020 none of this [__] existed I had
like three 4,000 followers and now a
[__] at a million and we go to the
world and we you feel me like he's he
found something early and invested in it
and now he gets Roi on that investment
and that's the way to go you ain't never
got to chase nothing just find the
things you love and help cultivate it
there it is man L Russell we're about to
do a freestyle you guys can watch
separate YouTube video huh um Everybody
uh make sure you check him in 2024
whatever City how many different cities
have you planned it out or do you just
kind of we know La is one of them yeah
we starting quarterly uh I got a spot in
a for you if you want to do Phoenix I
got a place we actually do I got a venue
out there a real dope venue shout out to
uh a way to active they're a dope
platform in Arizona that they got they
built a cool little venue and yeah man
it's going to be dope next year too cuz
like like I said it's just new like
[__] don't do residencies no more one
day I just had a thought I was like man
back in the days like if you want to go
see like a billy holiday that used to be
like a club that you go to and she
performing there for so many nights and
even comedians they go repeat the same
Comedy Club over and over and new people
sometimes do three shows in I'm on
that's what I that's what I want to I
like you cuz you do afternoon shows man
probably too tired and watch home
because the Granny's my demographic is
different I got grandmothers and
children they not trying to be out at 9
2 3 p.m. show I'm like oh this is yeah
this is what I like still right it's new
it'll spoil you cuz then you got to go
to another show and is like I'm tired
every time there's a concert I'm like
oh like do I really have already seen
him are they my friend right even even
if they're my friend how mad will they
be if I don't go it' be rough it' be
rough like recently I went and saw sizor
and I I did not regret it I was like I
love scor I was like you know what I got
to go see SI bro we got to build new
standards and new Norms like that
doesn't have to be the thing but we've
just been so conditioned to do it that
way and I I'm trying to break all them
barriers boom my guy appreciate you the
Russell go follow him go support him
stream the music buy a shirt buy a
hoodie boom appreciate you guys watching
hey this interview was brought to you by
odd Soxs baby the holidays are here and
the people who you love deserve the fly
socks the most comfortable socks in the
world oh these Scarface socks oh look at
these things look at these Top Ramen
socks what are we talking about whatever
you're into WWE Scarface uh The
Godfather [__] Transformers Power
Rangers Ghostbusters Breaking Bad uh
Coca-Cola hello you know I mean they got
the socks for them and they are the most
comfortable socks in the world get some
odd Soxs Basics on your feet and thank
me later odd Soxs official.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20% off
at checkout for the holiday season
appreciate youall watching